deadpool is such an iconic character
there's just got to be so many deadpools
you know like this last halloween i mean
did you see a ton of them i did i saw
lots of i saw quite a few of them yeah
where we went out trick-or-treating i uh
i saw like probably 10 or 12 deadpools
running around i was uh i was the 40
year old guy wearing a cheap uh mask he
bought at target who was begging his
wife to get home by 8 pm really yeah
which mask did you get i really did go
to a target generic gorilla mask yeah
phoned it right in
yeah that's pretty lame yeah it's
extraordinarily lame you can also just
put a cowboy hat on and say i'm tex
that's uh that's true that's true i've
done that before yeah yeah that's what
takes it to a new lane say i hate you uh
yeah
you went out last year year before this
halloween as deadpool did you not yes i
did i think we have a picture of that
and you found some kids yeah let's take
a look at that x-men
right there
did they even know
did those kids know that that was you
no yeah they they i think a couple of
them figured it out but most of them had
no idea they just wanted their 40 in a
bucket of candy